MALE SPEAKER: We're going to
be traveling across the country
to hear about how the Google
Maps API has helped developers
to build great apps, and
build their businesses on it.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Road trip.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
We have a 1959 GM
bus that's going to be
driving from here, all the way
to Disney.
MALE SPEAKER: Code
the Road bus is
a rolling museum of really
cool demos of our partners,
using the Maps API.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're here
at our first stop, at I/O.
And the developer
feedback has been amazing.
MALE SPEAKER: Have any of you
used the Maps APIs before?
MALE SPEAKER: My
entire app runs on it.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, fantastic.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Next stop, Logan.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm
here in Logan, Utah,
at the headquarters of iFit,
the world's first digital five
kilometer run.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You're
getting this amazing workout.
It was so fun.
MALE SPEAKER: iFit and Google
have completely changed the way
that you view fitness.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We just
made it to Milwaukee,
to meet with Harley-Davidson.
FEMALE SPEAKER: The
ride planner application
does a lot for our customers.
And Google Places and Google
Maps, layered on top of that,
really make it
all come together.
MALE SPEAKER: I got
Patrick, and we're
getting ready to take
him over to the Code
the Road Google meet-up.
PATRICK SKOGLUND:
It's good sitting down
with other developers,
to get behind the scenes.
When you look at
Google Maps, you're
able to do so many things.
LARRY OLSZAC: What the
Google tool allowed us to do
is bring that all together,
then look at these points,
and help the city
save dollars and time.
MALE SPEAKER: We're here today
in New York with our friends
from Sesame Street.
ELMO: Elmo would go, go,
go with you anywhere.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All about
location, location, location.
FEMALE SPEAKER: If I
wanted to see my view,
and I knew a room was right
here, I could just see my view.
And then, that helps
you choose your room.
I use it every
single time I travel.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm down here
in lovely Atlanta, Georgia,
with the Weather Channel for
the Code the Road hackathon.
MALE SPEAKER: Right
now, developers
are hacking upstairs, coming
up with innovative ideas.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm here at
EPCOT, in Orlando, Florida,
to show tech sassy girls
some interesting things
about coding.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Not many people get
to experience what
we experienced today.
FEMALE SPEAKER: What
better way to end
a trip than at Disney World?